la question se pose dans de nombreux
pays lusage thérapeutique du cannabis
peut-il être dépénalisée aujourd'hui la
france dit non
le canada en revanche malgré les
réticences du gouvernement a tranché une
courte de l'état de l'ontario a même
contraint les autorités à fournir de la
marijuana aux malades qui le demandaient
laurence et cherche des kilos de felou
de graines de cannabis prêts à être
distribués
le gouvernement canadien a pour
obligation de fournir l'herbe à près de
600 personnes souffrant de maladies
graves en donnant raison consommateurs
de marijuana à des fins thérapeutiques
le tribunal de l'ontario a lancé un
ultimatum au gouvernement
pourtant très réticents il n'existe
aucune étude nulle part dans le monde
capable de confirmer les bénéfices
médicaux 30 g de feuilles par mois pour
150 dollars canadiens ou un paquet de
graines par an pour 20 dollars les
malades autorisé à fumer du cannabis
dans un but médical ne sont pourtant pas
satisfait du plan du gouvernement qui
prévoit de leur faire payer la drogue
c'est un écran de fumée
avec la force pour alison atteintes de
dystrophie musculaire c'est un bon début
mais ça ne suffit pas obligés de se
déplacer en fauteuil roulant elle
souhaite 90 grammes de cannabis par
semaine pour soulager ses douleurs
à quel âge peut pas débourser 450
dollars canadiens je sais pas où je peux
les trouver
les médecins chargés d'être les
intermédiaires refuse de jouer les
dealers en faisant appel de ce jugement
le gouvernement lui se réserve le droit
de suspendre ce programme sens prêt